okay friends
all right uh fantastic our next speaker
is peter biel
and peter without further ado i'll let
you take it away
all right can everybody see my uh
presentation
can you make it full screen uh let's see
how about now let me get rid of the
black border uh no we're seeing your
we're seeing the uh the editable version
of your
obvious slides seeing the editable
version of my slide
just the desktop oh
got it okay let me
stop sharing for a moment by sharing
sharing your desktop instead of the
application
that might work better yeah as a
downside i can't see anything else
that's going on so that's how i was
trying to do it this way but
um let me try one more time this way
to see if it can
work directly this way
um
how about now that is better
can you see the full slide yes thank you
okay great well lee hong and uh mark
thanks
so much for inviting me and uh very
excited to be here already learned
many things this morning thank you um to
medina and
um uh oh yeah thank you in the name who
came before me
yeah um and looking forward to our panel
later
uh i want to focus on one very specific
work that we've been
doing recently on weighted bellman
losses for improved signal to noise in
queue updates
and this is worked together with uh
keemon lee misha laskin who are both
postdocs at berkeley and arvind srinivas
who's a
pc student at berkeley
so often when running q learning um
what happens is you might encounter some
instability so if you run q learning
naively
you update your q function with a target
value
and that would be reward plus discount
factor times
max our actions of q value at the next
state
but if that next state st plus 1 is
not been seen yet or not been seen very
often
and you haven't seen any related states
then it's very likely of a high error in
um that target q value or if just some
actions
in that state haven't been seen then the
max over actions
might result in a very high error in
your target q value
and so when you run q learning this will
just propagate into your q value for
state st action t
and then you know things can destabilize
of course people have found
various tricks to deal with this and
probably the most common trick
is to keep around two q values so
maybe an older one or maybe just two
separate networks
and that's done in double dqm which kind
of introduces that as
the mainstream thing to do but then
since then it's also been adopted in
uh td 3 sac and pretty much anything
that uses q functions these days
will have two queue functions and then
compute the max
to find the arg max and use the other q
function to then pass
on or possibly just pass on the minimum
of the two q values
to stabilize so effectively bringing the
q values down avoiding blow up
but in the process you're actually
losing a lot of signal also there's no
reason to believe that the
lower q value is necessarily more
precise
it's just more stable and so the
question we're trying to look at is okay
yes more stable is good but can we also
try to get more signal
in the process and we'll you know we'll
have to do some extra computation but
we're willing to do that here so what if
we could somehow
in our q q learning laws weigh
the terms by some confidence score about
the target value so if we somehow could
know whether
target value is likely precise or not
likely precise we could put a waiting
term there
and then based on that um update our q
values or
optimize our q function laws
now question then is how do you quantify
the uncertainty on a target value well
that's actually pretty well understood
how that can be done
uh it's not necessarily perfect but it
can work pretty well
which is to keep around an ensemble so
let's say we have an ensemble of
q functions we can uh have insert the
estimates from that
that has been shown before to you know
work pretty well and
let's say deep exploration free uh
bootstrap dqm
or the work by a lecturer or an audience
you're also using deep ensembles to do
uncertainty estimation
so imagine we have an ensemble then we
can use it to really weight
so we can look at the variance we have
an ensemble each member of the ensembl
computes a target q value
we can look at the variance of those
target q
values and then reweight and our
investigation initially we
actually tried to reweight by one over
the variance or one over the standard
deviation but we found that didn't work
all that well empirically and so we then
investigated just
three weighting by the sigmoid of the
negative standard deviation
plus 0.5 so we kind of everything gets
at least some kind of weight we can't
drive the weight of
anything to zero everything between 0.5
and 1 in the waiting
and empirically that worked best for us
now i know it's a
workshop for theory of reinforcement
learning so
um a lot of opportunity for more theater
here this this is just a
purely empirical observation that
using the sigmoid on the negative
standard deviation and then bumping it
up by 0.5
to not discard anything uh even if we're
very uncertain very high standard
deviation we don't want to discard it we
still
included in our updates and so then we
have a weighted domain backup loss
as a consequence with these sigmoid
weightings
now once we have an ensemble might as
well use it for other things
so uh another way to use an ensemble is
to use it for exploration um if you
doing action action selection for taking
the actions not for your queue updates
before taking your actions
you could look at the standard deviation
and use it as a bonus to favor actions
that you know you have more uncertainty
about than ones that you already know a
lot about
so in what i'll present in the
experimental experimental results
it'll be a combination of both the wave
weighted
bellman losses and ucd exploration
applied by having the variance from the
ensemble
one thing that's uh worth
highlighting here is that when we use
so let's take a look at the algorithm
actually and step through it there
when when we use ucb exploration we use
optimistic or use the variance in an
optimistic way
but that doesn't propagate directly into
any queue updates
when we put together the q
q learning loss we use the weighting
that i described
and we use an ensemble where each
ensemble is learned completely
separately
so one natural thing you might want to
do with an ensemble is to
average and say hey the average of the
ensemble will actually give me a
more precise estimate of the target q
value than any single one of them
the reason we did not do that maybe
there's a way to do it but the reason we
did not do it is because once you start
passing on the average your ensemble
becomes
coupled everything starts learning
together and it's not
clear that you would still get good
variance estimates so to keep things
separate we pass
on individual q functions uh values
from each ensemble member is being
trained separately the only coupling
is that the variance is computed by
looking at all of them
okay so we have ucd exploration
and then we have these weighted bellman
backups but otherwise it's just like
regular q learning
we looked at a few different
environments openi gym which is
an environment where we work based on
state deep mind control suite which has
very similar environments but there we
use the pixel inputs rather than
state input and then atari with also
visual inputs and attire there's
discrete action the other two have
continuous action
so an openid gym um
we looked at four of the most standard
environments cheetah
walker and hopper and ant we compared
with
some model based rl methods
as they tend to be quite sample
efficient pets poplin
metrperio and also looked at td3 which
in some sense is the most direct
comparison and sac
td3 uses the min of the q functions sast
uses this kind of
swap max thing i believe so
what we see is that sunrise which
applies ucb exploration
and weighted belmont backups
consistently outperforms sac which
it's directly based upon so we see a
direct benefit
of these two uh changes uh across
all domains model-based there alpoplin
still
outperforming in one of the environments
that's kind of a pretty
kind of an autonomous choice
so then um what happened is
we um looked at uh humanoid
where training actually takes a lot
longer so in our initial experiments we
ignored humanoid
but then we were encouraged to take a
look at humanoid trend longer
all the previous experiments are for 200
000 steps
look at humanoid at 200 000 steps that's
right over here
nothing has really happened yet either
for shc or
for sunrise which we call our approach
but it turns out if you run it for
longer
all of a sudden you start seeing a
pretty big separation
between the two environments so here we
ran it for you know
800 000 steps instead of two hundred
thousand
and so it seems like the longer you
train you can continue to
uh accrue more benefits
we then looked at the mind control suite
which has pixel inputs
rather than uh state input so here we
build upon
rad rad is soft director critic
with extensive data augmentation
during the training drq is actually
very similar to rad but we happen to
have a rad implementation
and so we built it on top of that and so
the first thing to see here is that
once we add the two components ucdb and
with the domain backups we see
we have consistent outperforming of
rad or in the very last line here
equally good everything else
outperforming rad which means we have
consistent benefit from this
it's not literally always
state-of-the-art dr q
has a few environments where it's a
little better than rad and
we don't beat it with sunrise but
the direct comparison to rad is
consistently improving it
then looking at atari
here we build on rainbow which is a
state-of-the-art model-free method
and uses q-learning so it's a direct fit
with
what we're looking at here and we see
that we get
fairly consistent uh that sunrise
outperforms
rainbows are adding the ucb exploration
and the weighted bellman backups is
consistently better than
not having them um overall on atari
we see that model bistrol here simple
uh actually still uh that's best about
half of the
for half of the games also want to point
out that this is at 100 000 interactions
so this is really looking at how fast do
you pick up the learning in atari there
are many other benchmarks in atari where
you look at
50 million or 200 million interactions
which
is also interesting but here we're
focused on how fast can you start
learning
uh so state-of-the-art on half of the
environments
then we did a bit of an ablation uh
because
there are effectively three components
at play here um there is the ucp
exploration part there is the weighted
bellman backups
and there's the fact that we're doing a
bootstrap which you can just do on its
own
uh as done the original bootstrap paper
which was shown to maybe also help a bit
with
exploration today we looked at a noisy
reward setting from the discord paper
the idea here is that if you want to
really investigate how much benefit you
get from
the weighted bell on backups and dig
deeper into it it's convenient to
introduce additional
noise in the in the reward signal
because that's the kind of thing that
you
don't want to propagate you want to make
sure that you see you're able to avoid
propagating it too much
and so the discord paper is actually
specifically looking at that at
this setting where there is potential
propagation of noise in the reward and
that's the orange curve
and then what we see here is that the
approach
we followed sunrise actually is better
at
extracting signal over noise than uh
what they did there where they weighted
their bellman backups also
just like we're doing here there's a
waiting but they waited based on some
estimated
cumulative bellman errors rather than
using an ensemble
so using ensemble seems more robust at
least in these evaluations than
the weighted bellman backup cumulative
estimates they had
which is closer to prioritized
experience replay type
measurements of error so
a couple of takeaways and to wrap up
here uh it seems ensembles can be used
to prevent
error propagation in q learning uh not
just to prevent
error propagation but also extract more
signal than you would get from just
using the min
or swapping the max and the arc max as
is commonly done
some future directions more
investigations
of this in offline rl which i know is
topic
uh yesterday or day before um
i think it could help there too because
a lot of the challenges there are about
whether you're getting signal or noise
as you're doing updates
it could help in imitation learning uh
which is very related to offline rl
because
you get a lot of expert data and you can
decide um
a big challenge limitation learning is
that you would go off the expert's path
and
would not know what to do there and over
fit to things off the experts path
this can be avoided here maybe
and then the question is how to extend
to on policy learning i'll give
a little bit about that we've done a
bunch of experiments to extend it to on
policy learning
and we have not found so far this
and any substantial benefits yet uh
compared to what we're seeing here
uh our intuition there is that with on
policy learning
you get more automatic corrections you
don't get that error propagation
happening the way you get in off policy
learning because in on policy learning
uh you're evaluating the current policy
so you're not really trying to go off
the beaten path
and not pulling in values that you don't
know much about
and so the benefit might not really
exist there
and then we have a pre-painted archive
and the code is available
thank you
thank you peter this is great uh we have
about 10
10 to 12 minutes for questions uh i'll
let the panelists start
um peter great talk um i thought that
was really interesting um particularly
given the importance of
uncertainty calibration one question i
had was um you're using ensembles to
quantify the uncertainty um but my
understanding is that the ensembles are
good at sort of quantifying statistical
uncertainty due to finite amounts of
data
but if we have model misspecification
they're not going to be able to handle
sort of bias and the function
approximations that we're using
do you think that's a problem in these
cases or do you feel like for most of
the types of benchmarks we look at
deep neural networks are sufficiently
expressive that that sort of bias is not
a concern
that's a very good question it'd be good
for us to think about how to piece that
apart in these experiments we definitely
haven't explicitly
tried to tease that apart and it seems
like we could
um as you said if let's let's say we
just use smaller
networks at some point we might start
hitting the limits
of what they can represent i think i
mean
as as you know even though it's a
workshop for theory of dprl in my lab
we tend to be more focused on pragmatics
than theory on average
and so we kind of just make the networks
larger until
we don't run in that problem it seems
but i do think it's a very valid
question and especially in
maybe domains where you can introduce a
lot more prior knowledge
in the structure of what you learn and
you want to introduce that but you might
have a little bit of
a bias that's introduced and how to deal
with that i think it's a really good
question and i don't have a full answer
at this point if it would
be able to deal with that yeah
uh peter thanks for the great talk um
this is really impressive result um so i
i just have a very naive question
um it seems that when when you down
weigh the uh samples with
high uncertainty um it seems there is a
there might be another interpretation
from uh using the principle of pessimism
when you
learn from finite data i know these two
are different
but do you think there might be a
connection uh
to that line of work where um
the updates are downloaded or using more
conservative updates
as opposed to down waiting on certain
samples
yeah it's interesting you bring that up
because um one of the things
well first of all yes there's a strong
connection one of the things we notice
is that
if you if you run weighted bellman
backups
without the uctb um
the benefits are a lot more limited and
we've been thinking a bit about why that
would be
and part of why would be is our thing
has been
well you're less off policy because you
explore less
without ucb if you just do some
boltzmann exploration you're
also exploration effectively on policy
it's turning q learning pretty much into
you know soft actor critics so you stay
on pause that's one thing
but i think there might be an additional
effect there which is what you're
alluding to lihong which is
it becomes pessimistic a little bit
possibly or at least it's definitely not
optimistic and you're taking you're
actually taking away some exploration
possibilities by doing this and that
maybe you
do explicitly need to combine
the weighted backups with ucb or some
other more explicit exploration
mechanism
to to avoid these issues
and then on the flip side if you're in a
setting where you want to be
conservative
i think yes it will help you be
conservative
i have a question
you you wait so all terms optimization
problem
but in your internal motivation it was
to not uh bootstrap
terms that you cannot believe so why not
just waiting gamma by
uh omega have you tried it
so that you can at least propagate the
reward
oh that's that's an interesting question
um
and yeah
i feel like that wouldn't i'm not sure
how how to how to do that
looking at this equation but there might
be a way because the the target key
value has reward
plus the noisy estimate of the q value
and they get combined so
yeah i think i think if you want to be
conservative
if the goal is to be conservative and
stabilize i could see that
being effective it's
less clear what it does
aside from stabilizing because you're
cutting out one of the two
terms which is
isn't that going to change the problem
because essentially you've changed your
gamma for that state
if i understand the suggestion
yes you would change gamma from the
state but depending on the
certainty you have on the q value that
you want to bootstrap
so at least if you're uncertain about
value you can disrupt water or you can
look at smaller reason and it's
what makes a q value if you put gamma to
zero everything is easy
and i'm a bit exaggerating but uh
it's it's easier with smaller gamma
so you because here you somehow lose
part of the information by uh putting uh
you you lose part of the rod information
locally
yeah it was just an idea one thing
well i think there might be something
that can be done i'm not sure the exact
format we're discussing right now will
work but i do agree that there's a
there's a big difference the reward
often is certain you know exactly what
it is and the
future state q value has a lot of
uncertainty and treating them
specifically and to account for that
yeah i think it could be interesting um
and
this is definitely not doing that
i thank you i have some questions or two
related comments i mean very interesting
idea
so uh one is basically by changing w
you are effectively changing the problem
that is being solved
uh like the underlying distribution of
this
the data would be changed uh so i guess
one question is that
uh why this choice and kind of related
question is that
what is the optimal w like if you have
all the information in the board
uh how do we want to choose that w
that's
implement what we actually want to get
out of it like reducing the error
propagation
or something like that
yeah at the one step level i think it's
it's maybe not too hard to think about
because at the one step level
i think i think we can see this as a i
mean
a simpler version would be running
linear regression where we have
uncertainty estimates
on the target values and you would
re-weight them um
you would probably not re-weight them by
a sigmoid
i mean you would probably reweight them
by the things we tried initially which
is
one one over the variance of one over
standard deviation however the math
works out
to have kind of if you assume some kind
of gaussian prior and uncertainties
and you could do it exactly that way um
what's different here well one the
gaussian assumption might be wrong
so that might be why that weighting
didn't work well and there's the
propagation effect that you alluded to a
mirror that also makes it more complex
to
to think through what what the perfect
thing is to do i think
yeah i'd be very curious if somebody can
figure out what is the you know
theoretically correct way to do this um
i'm definitely not gonna you know claim
that this is
guaranteed to be the thing that comes
out of that um
but hopefully it's somewhat close
okay thank you
i also saw a question in the q a about
the footprint
of this so that's a really good question
so we found that
um using five uh
neural networks for the ensemble is
enough to pretty much have all the
benefits at least in the environments
that we worked in
so yes the footprint does become
five networks rather than one uh in
practice you can you don't have to have
five completely
joint discharge networks you can also
have networks with shared core and then
separate heads to save some memory
footprint and people often already use
two so it's going from two to five
really rather than from from one to five
but yeah there's definitely an
additional memory footprint there
and competition footprint for that
matter because for every update you're
gonna do
five times the competition effectively
uh compared to
normally one time
can i ask you a question sure there's
sort of this discussion going along in
the chat so maybe it's
maybe this has been answered and i
missed it because i was looking at the
chat but uh
there's a question about how this
affects the waiting on the states and
that you know
state reading matters for function
approximation so do you know
do you have an idea of where this weight
converges to like where wsa goes to i
mean i know it's changing as time passes
and then you know where might it go to
is it going to become uniform eventually
because you're equally confident
about everything or or what's going to
happen
i i i can make a guess but
we have not looked at it i mean educated
guess i would make would be that
as it converges the q values become the
same
across all the members of the ensemble
and so
the weighting would go to one
um but yeah we should probably check
great that makes sense
all right uh we're almost out of time
but actually i'm going to be quite
selfish as a moderator and i think peter
i could spend a whole afternoon picking
your brain about this so i have a
question for you
a very practical question um there's an
alternate way to implement the weighting
as you've done here which is to use the
weights as priorities and you've sort of
alluded to this right you could do
prioritize replay
and just then weigh everything by one uh
have you looked into this is there
what's your feeling that one should work
better than the other
and if your samples if you do enough of
it i think
the right market would effectively be
just the same because
you would just do more updates that are
awaited by one but
more updates for certain terms than for
others um
if you yeah it's interesting these
people don't really do prioritize
experience replay this way
when so essentially maybe the way i've
practically interpreted is hey maybe
there's an opportunity to
you know experiment with prioritized
experience replay
using this as the signal and see what
happens
that's right um the reason i'm asking is
because i'm thinking
this is something actually we've looked
at and it seems like if you're if you're
not not the the version you're
presenting here today but if your
weights are very small
then effectively it's a wasted graded
update which you would rather react
to train on a different sample right now
in your case you're only
you're keeping them at point five maybe
note samples are wasted and maybe that's
why that wouldn't make a difference
but uh yeah i mean we experiment with
not capping up
0.5 and letting it go to zero and that
didn't work so well uh just as an
additional bit of information
um i know prioritize replays actually
can be quite finicky because
it introduces additional variants in the
process maybe that's a reason to weigh
them instead of
sampling yeah i'm very curious now let's
see if that might work
sounds good on this note
if there is a quick question we could
take a question otherwise we can also
thank the speakers any other questions
before we wrap up
oh good then thank you again peter thank
you all the speakers this morning
the next uh step is for us to have a
coffee break
and recover from zoom fatigue uh after
which we'll have
one more talk uh after the break and uh
followed by a discussion i always get my
time zones wrong
um but it is in an hour for the
discussion is this
the coffee break lasts half an hour and
the discussion is an hour from now
uh so thank you very much all and see
you in half an hour
we will start at 2 p.m sharp eastern
time thank you